hello freak [ __ ] and then at an NYU I
was going to that talk I got
pepper-sprayed perfectly legal if they
can argue that know who pepper sprayed
you and did you see the person doing it
do you know who they are they are all
the same they're all middle class kids
of professors they all live at home they
all look exactly the same they look
British how do you like British I don't
know they have like these angular
features and these Roman noses and
glasses they all look exactly the same
nothing Italian about them you know now
what was it that they pepper sprayed you
about were you actually give an order to
a stalkers and go by the Colossians
I started this gang called the proud
boys and boys the proud boys
what is it was proud boys about we have
chapters all over the world we meet our
duty on chapters we get drunk and just
it's like the Elks Lodge okay like
Masons or whatever celebrating manhood
yeah no women allowed oh wow can't tell
your woman what goes on the meetings and
we have different degrees like the
Knights of Columbus first degree you
declare yourself a broad boy second
degree we'd beat the [ __ ] out of you
until you can imply breakfast cereals
and you're masturbating and then third
degree you still have to give up
masturbating but you have to get a
tattoo and then fourth degree you get
arrested or in a serious violent fight
for the really yes you get arrested in a
serious violent fight to your promoter
if I'm sort of major altercation you
shouldn't that we should erase that part
well we don't we don't encourage it but
if you're defending like at the at the
Berkeley thing with Milo we just my guys
just 14 and just walked into a mob 200
people just together stripes that I
thought you guys were tough no they were
doing it just for fun and these people
outside a pepper spray and clubs they
can't fight like at the NYU thing
my guys were beating them up and he goes
this one guy we call Friar Tuck because
he's just a monster he goes I started to
feel like batting I started feeling bad
after a while because I was just I could
tell these kids have never been in a
fight and I was just mowing through them
they're terrible fighters what is he
fighting like this is what confuses me
like why are they getting so angry that
they're hitting people and spraying that
girl in the face the girl was really
disturbing because she was talking to
someone
she wasn't offering any
threat and she she had a hat that looked
like a make America great again hat but
it said make Bitcoin great again they
walk up to her the guy hits her with a
stick that's holding a sign so he hits
her in the head with a piece of wood and
she's like what the [ __ ] and someone
sprays her in the face with pepper spray
I mean it's like how in any way how
could you ever in any other scenario
justify beating a woman publicly for
doing nothing but representing what you
think is offensive and you're even wrong
about what she's representing here's the
problem with what you're doing and I did
this too much to your intellectualizing
a fashion movement this is the mods and
the rockers in Brighton Beach
in 1961 just fighting each other because
one likes Elvis and the other likes the
WHO and if you were to sit down with
this modernist rocker and say have a
debate they wouldn't say anything they
have nothing to say it's leather versus
parkas it's Vespas worth versus triumph
or motorbikes there's no context there
so this guy is on this team and she's on
the other team and that their tool is
pepper spray and that's what they're
doing there's no that's they pretend I
want to give you a platform no they
don't want to give you and anything
because they don't have anything to say
in fact at the NYU talk I after I
watched the pepper sprayed I went and
did the talk they're all screaming whose
campus our campuses and I walk over the
mob with a microphone and I have to and
I come on up come on up and it was a
radioactive [ __ ] I was handing him like
he would just went oh uh it was a Mike
he shriveled up because he wanted to be
a part of the big group right and didn't
want to be an individual with an opinion
and didn't exactly know why he was there
in the first place exactly know what he
was protesting against that's why like
Milo's would kill to debate any of these
people he's been scrounging from the
real problem is that they're not
debating that's the real problem I feel
like this could be really productive if
people could sit down and Milo by the
way will debate you I mean he might say
outrageous things he might say offensive
things but he will debate he will sit in
front of a podium here we always time
and anyone else well they will have
their time and they will be able to take
questions from the audience and this
could be very productive and you could
kind of figure out like what you and I
are not
far left and we're not far right you
know neither one of us are we're worse
in some sort of a weird way I think I'm
more maybe more left than you are but
I'm not as less as a lot of people I
know and there's a lot of people out
there and I think this left white right
paradigm is really kind of [ __ ]
foolish at this point and we should kind
of figure out like what's what's uh
what's what kind of opinions are okay to
have because they don't interfere with
anybody else's life and it's just your
philosophy and the way you look at the
world you should be able to express that
opinion and express those ideas in front
of someone else who has an opposing idea
and they tell you why they disagree and
you should be able to consider why they
disagree and see if there's any merit in
that the problem you're with what you're
saying is you're implying that these are
all informed people right and left and
they need to hash out ideas no these
people on the right are intelligent
people who have looked it up and wanted
to bait you want to see a debate socket
Pat Buchanan versus Sean Hannity or
Peter Brimelow
versus some open borders libertarian
like Matt Walsh or something or someone
from The Wall Street Journal all the
inner right fights are fascinating to me
these people are religious fanatics they
they for them it's sports it's the
Dallas Cowboys is there a team and they
want to [ __ ] up your team they don't
want debate like Jared Diamond who did
Guns Germs and Steel tons of flaws with
that book Steve Saylor was begging him
for a debate he wouldn't answer
Jared Taylor John Derbyshire all these
rich even working in Spencer all these
far-right guys have made it clear they
love to argue with anyone on the other
side and the other side knows that they
will lose because their foundation is in
truth or information their foundation is
just emotions we're a nation of
immigrants so everything's racist though
gays are people too and you like you
think I don't think gays are [ __ ]
people what is your point I don't even
understand your side of things right
well you I'm sure you saw that woman
who's a middle school teacher who was a
part of the protest at Berkeley yeah
yeah he was on a carlson tucker carlson
show and she was talking about fascism
and she said that Milo is homophobic
even [ __ ] gay yeah he's a racist
homophobe who sucks black [ __ ] yeah it's
so hilarious and she was also saying
that
promotes genocide like you can't just
throw those labels out and that that
mean it's a clear example what we're
talking about because those labels allow
her to do anything necessary to get you
out right necks right and that's fascism
that is fascist yeah that's a sorry
Katie
that's authoritative thinking you
authoritarian thinking you know in a way
that's eliminating someone else from
expressing themselves because you have
deemed them unworthy of expressing
himself theraph this is a racist this is
a homophobe
this is someone who promotes genocide we
will shut them down like you that's
that's nonsense and you could see from
her talking on that show that she she
talks over him she doesn't express
herself well she doesn't have clearly
thought-out reasons for why she's saying
no he does he think she doesn't have
quotes as she's relying on she doesn't
say why it's so dangerous that he has
these controversial opinions she just
says he's a Nazi he's a racist
he's a homophobe he promotes genocide
we're going to shut him down but you
can't just say that you can't just label
people because someone could do that to
you too and they will they will that's
the problem I forget her name Michelle
you fellas it doesn't even matter what
her name is she really a my car by any
means necessary but I I like playing
with these people is play it through
they do that at AAA
they go you want a beer okay have a beer
then you can have another beer then
you're going to get coke and the heroin
but a lot play it's right and I always
say these people play it through so he
wants genocide Trump wants genocide okay
so he wants to kill like blacks and
Mexicans so there's a van that drives to
this house in New Orleans and picks up
these black people and then they what
they go to a gas chamber how does this
work what happens to their property is
that divvied up there's a state on that
now like are you talking about the Cuban
Revolution the irony is by the way
whenever you start describing their
universe you end up describing Venezuela
Cuba socialist countries or you end up
describing the Middle East always going
to want throw gays off buildings he's
gonna start stoning women to that
through her rape victims
you have your villains right there but
you're purposely ignoring them and the
other thing that's going on here which
is still a theory I'm working on but
there seems to be a disturbing peek at
what a matriarchy would be like and I'm
seeing a lot of women in
these movements who are sort of
vindictive and and cruel and like this
woman we're talking about you know you
watch these videos and you hear like
[ __ ] em up get them get them these women
voices from behind the crowd and I call
them chit chat like that woman from the
University of Missouri can I get some
muscle over here ya never heard yeah
yeah yeah yeah she wants men to fight on
her behalf and you know iron man has
that blue thing in his chest yeah I
don't think women are evil I like our
women are like iron man they're magic
right but by ripping out that blue thing
you're ripping out their ability to have
children and be mothers and everything
and then you put in a piece of [ __ ] into
Iron Man's Chest
that's what feminists and like this
woman are their [ __ ] chest and they're
malfunctioning robot you know like kill
them milo wants genocide killed so do
you like that they're imitating what
they think our patriarchal societies
they're doing their version of it and
that's what they're doing with this the
whole matriarchal posturing yeah it's
like Clark Kent I want to write an
article ah I'm ready no you're not
letting you go Clark simmer down dude
you write your article I'm doing mine no
any crunches oh there's a whole lot of
matriarchal societies in the animal
world other than hyenas I try it there's
a few of them the few where the females
are larger than the males a few bugs
especially but hyenas in particular the
female hyenas are much larger than the
males even at fake dicks really what
faux pas has big large tube fake dick
that hangs down they actually give birth
out of it and they climb on top of the
males and they [ __ ] them and the
speculation what there's a lot of
speculation as to why the females are
bigger but one of them is that they
think that she has to be bigger those
kyna's are so goddamn ruthless they eat
their babies Oh
the female has to go get the [ __ ] away
from the baby cousin she gets on top of
him [ __ ] so I mean pieces [ __ ] it's my
baby I mean there's no more you know no
pun intended dog-eat-dog world than a
[ __ ] hyena world you know they're
fighting for scraps with lions yeah well
I actually have described an tyfa and
these people as hyenas because that
thing I was talking about at Berkeley
where their guys went in and said I
thought you guys were
like tough for something was his exact
quote and they're going to get him get
him [ __ ] him up and then the guys sort
of give up because no one wants to fight
them they start walking away and then
someone runs up behind him knocks him
out with a flagpole as they're screaming
he's Italian slogans by the way like
know why she stopped on before she
stopped I'm from the 1920s they're
having fun they knock you have a game
they're LARPing and then knock them out
and then a student sees out that the
hyenas come out then they start kicking
his unconscious body and they start
driving they're really high like your
little yes online you can find Oh
we're little ugly Savage here's the
scary thing man you're going to invite
right-wing people to do the same thing
and you're going to get some some
veterans and you're going to get some
fighters and you do and it's it's going
to be horrific man it's going to be
horrific and again you start kicking
their ass and then they're going to come
back with weapons and people are going
to show up with guns it always leads to
someone showing up with guns maybe and
if this keeps going
[Music]